[Music]
hi I'm Devin today I'm going to walk you
through how I restore a 200 year old
grandfather clock
's that old weren't branded with
anything other than just the
clockmaker's name a single person built
the entire thing this particular one is
Abraham shawf of billing Borough so an
English clock my customer brought it
from England to the U.S she inherited
this from her parents who inherited from
their parents who inherited it from
their parents back to Ballpark 1820s
pre-restoration this clock is probably
not worth much I'd say maybe 500 at most
probably less
the case definitely is in the need of
more attention than the mechanism the
whole case has come apart
I like to start with the cleaning just
to make sure there's not going to be any
kind of dust or debris or with all clock
spider webs it's going to be in the way
of you know re-gluing everything
the next step after I clean it is start
approaching some of the wood repairs I
always never have to fix a case this bad
of condition
this case was
in serious need of help the parts of a
clock case the names of them vary each
country would call them different things
but typically for an English clock you
would have the Bonnet which is the hood
basically just slides off it has the
front door to it and then typically some
type of decoration to make the clock
look nice then you have the trunk which
is just the main body of the clock where
if you have a door you could see the
pendulum and the weights the base of the
clock is is the buck the bottom Square
section
the floor of the clock was broken and
half of it missing so I just do a couple
quick measurements on the inside and cut
out a new piece
this is the most common broken thing on
grandfather clocks
if there's some type of failure from the
weights the weights come crashing down
and when you get a 200 year old clock
chances are it's missing the bomb
so I attached the floor to the to the
base by using glue and nails
into the nails just help the glue dry
properly
the top right trim piece of the hood is
often in very bad condition I was left
with decisions to make there and I just
decided to keep the original piece
it was a little difficult to tell what
was actually the cause of that top
corner but my best guess and a few other
clock makers I gave me an idea was most
likely bugs of some sort and that if it
rotted from there
the first thing I needed to do was
copy its profile
there was no good place to copy it on
this piece because it was damaged pretty
much all over so I just went to the back
edge of the other side and just used a
piece of paper and a pencil
you know just get the profile for that
piece
and then I glue that to another piece of
wood
to cut that shape out and that piece of
wood is what we will end up calling a
form tool
and then I use a combination of Bondo
wood filler and and pink just to just to
get it close to the right color
initially and of course this clock would
have been stained originally so to try
to match that look I just used a
combination of brown red and black paint
to to mimic the the wood grain as best I
could I mix that up with the hardener
and apply it on in large copies amounts
onto the piece and make sure it's all
rubbed into all the nooks and crannies
so it's going to make a good joint
everywhere
and then I use that form tool that I
made to basically wipe off the excess
other than where I want it
I wouldn't call it fabrication but I did
have to for lack of better Tervis
fabricate that piece
[Music]
and then I cut it off the size so I give
it a 45 degree angle on the front where
it will meet the other piece and then
cut the back off just straight where it
will be at the back of the clock
and then I glue it down in this case I
did not use wood glue because I used
Bondo wood filler and I didn't want the
wood filler to make it so the joint
would not be strong so I used a general
purpose glue everything type of glue
which I wouldn't use on something
load-bearing but this is just an ornate
decorative piece on the side so that
glue will be sufficient for that
nine times out of ten wood glue is going
to be your best option
there's a lot of odd shapes on on this
so it's not easy to clamp clamps have to
be opposite from each other and you
don't always have that availability so I
usually use weights or something like
that in in place
easily the hardest part of this case
easily the hardest part was the glass
that could have been glazed in place 200
years ago and then at some point during
its life even that glass broke so I'm
left with a bunch of glazing that's full
of glass shards all throughout it
so there's no great way to get that old
glazing out the method I use is just
take a razor blade and scrape it out you
know take your time going around the
whole perimeter clean up as you go to
make sure none of the glass shards are
going to hurt the piece of wood
removing that previous glazing is is
very tedious and can hurt you
and then I put the glass in
and then I use a couple nails to to hold
the glass in while I glaze it
and uh that's it's it's straightforward
but definitely requires a steady hand
[Music]
I in between you work on the mechanism
so you know disassemble it
disassembly takes a lot of focus you
have to make sure you're paying
attention to where things are if you see
any kind of previous repairs because
previous repairs are usually a sign of
disaster
a lot of beginner clock makers or
hobbyists are attempted to not
disassemble the movement and duck it
straight into the Ultrasonic Cleaner
thinking that you it will it'll clean it
you know it's in there but you do need
to take everything apart not as much for
cleaning but more so for rinsing and
drying afterwards the solution will go
in between the little tiny parts that
they're still together and they won't it
won't come back out when you you try to
rinse it
you got to take the everything apart
down to the very last screw every last
pin and clean it that way in the
ultrasonic solution which needs to be
clock cleaning solution if it's just
brass cleaning solution or something
along those lines you can Flash rust to
steel or if you use steel cleaning
solution you can actually corrode the
brass
it sits there for ballpark 20 minutes
that solution stays on the parts the too
long it will ruin them
so you have to very very thoroughly
rinse it all off with water and then
water is just as bad as the solution if
you don't dry it off if you've got a
little bit of water stays stuck in a
corner it'll destroy the clock in a
matter of a couple years
now I'm gonna repair the mechanism
I start working on the pendulum the
pendulum was already at pieces when I
received it the Bob of the pendulum the
brass circle at the bottom is actually
how we determine how fast or slower
clock will run so it needs to be able to
slide up and down smoothly without any
kind of snagging or getting stuck so I
had to remove a very small amount of
material from the rod to make sure the
Bob could go up and down and then polish
that surface to make sure it's as close
to frictionless as possible
I actually found some witness marks on
this particular particular clock on the
rod there were some lines scratched and
I just went ahead and assumed that
that's where they wanted the pendulum
Bob set to so I go ahead I went ahead
and set it right there and put the screw
on underneath it and it actually worked
first try so that that uh that witness
Mark was correct
next I am polishing the pivots I'm not
focusing on the gear I'm actually
focusing on the Arbors for the gears at
the end of each Arbor there is a pivot
point that it will turn inside the
plates it's axle basically
clock parts have a lot of terminology
they don't match up with today gears are
not called gears they're called Wheels
axles are not called axles they're
called arbors
I use a lathe which is convenient
because it it turns everything
concentrically makes everything a lot
easier and turns out nicer in the end a
lathe is actively trying to kill you at
all times if you touch it it will not
stop so I use keep my fingers out of the
way by using paper and then if I have
enough room I actually use a very fine
abrasive Stones like an Arkansas Stone
which is just very fine fine grit we're
talking around like four thousand Grit
if you leave Jagged edges it doesn't
happen overnight but over the course of
a few years the the clock will actually
eat itself away if it's not smooth
smooth surfaces
the other end of them is their bearings
inside the plates the little holes and
the plates those that need the same
process they need to be cleaned very
thoroughly and then you know made sure
that they're polished properly where
it'll it'll have very little friction
the escapement palette is going to be
one of the most ignored things in a
clock but arguably the most important
this is what the pendulum is attached to
at the very top
that Groove that that's a fraction of
the thickness of a human hair
really really small
the Escape wheel has been hitting that
over and over again for many many years
the clock will not run accurately if
those grooves are there
most people when they repair clocks will
ignore this but I go ahead and repolish
those surfaces
we're putting in brass cable when I
picked it up it already had brass wire
but originally it would have had cap gut
cable which would have been made out of
cat guts that's exactly what it sounds
like
we use brass instead of Steel because
steel cable will actually tear up the
parts inside the clock but brass is what
the parts are made out of so it's hard
to tear up brass with brass you want
this to wrap around the barrel that it's
going on to the correct amount of times
and you also want it to have the weights
reach the bottom of the case in eight
days this is an eight day movement
there's a few things you got to be
careful of when assembling the mechanism
so the obvious one to make sure
everything's in the right place but
that's actually a lot less like a puzzle
than you think if you know what each
part does it only has one place to go
and then the difficult part is indexing
it where you don't just put it in the
right spot but it needs to be oriented
correctly when it goes there
so you need to have one part of a gear
meshing with another part of the gear
all those pivots that we polished are
very fragile so when you are putting
plates together you have to be very
careful and use very small amounts of
force to try to nudge everything into
its place and make sure that the pivots
go into the correct holes and aren't
damaged
that's that's definitely the art of
mixing the clock is is trying to close
the plates it's it takes a certain feel
once it's together then you get it up on
the test stand and make sure it's still
working right
and then there's actually a several week
period of testing every time I come into
the shop I see if it's running fast or
slow and make an adjustment
usually when I test it there I like to
get it to where everything is working
completely properly for a whole week
straight
then I put it into the case to test it
there to make sure it's all going to
continue to work properly
time at the workbench I spent probably
around two weeks or so
actually working on stuff you know it's
and that's I'm talking full hours of two
weeks
I'm pretty happy with this restoration
definitely the movement the movement was
you know every everything went according
to plan how I liked
the most satisfying part of this
restoration and and every restoration is
is definitely going to be one of two
things either either the first time the
clock ticks you know when I set it up in
it and it works that's that's extremely
satisfying to have that happen and the
other part is is the client when I
deliver it back it's extremely
satisfying to see these people's
reactions you know sometimes for clocks
that are shining clocks I'll bring it
back and they haven't heard a chime
since they were eight years old in their
grandparents house
you're only the temporary caretaker of
this clock
it's been around for 200 years you know
it's gonna outlive you so it's more
important to to do what is right for the
clock
I try to keep it original as much as I
possibly can at all times
[Music]